Blending is not only reserved for animations, but you can blend using physics too to get
some really unique results, and this can be used for things like maybe something hits
into your character and affects the animation that they're playing.
Or you can use it for things like a ponytail on your character, or a chain on a skeletal
mesh.
We'll be looking at two of the primary physics blending functions that we have inside the
animation blueprint.
We set all bodies below simulate physics and set all bodies below physics blend weight.
Now the primary difference between these two is, as you can imagine, the blend weight version
allows you to control the strength of the physics that you're applying to your character
or to your skeletal mesh.
So the first set all bodies below simulate physics is great for things like ponytails
or chains or anything that you want to be like a completely limp ragdoll.
The blend weight option allows you to control how strong that physics blend is going to
be on top of your animation, which is great for slight changes to reactions where something
might hit your character or if you want an arm to dangle if they've been shot, for example.
So we'll take a look in the engine and see how you set these two things up.
For physics to work with your character, you need to have a physics asset.
Now these are already set up for our character engine, but you can create one by right clicking
your character, coming up to create and choosing physics asset.
If you choose create and assign, this is going to assign, well, this is going to create the
new physics asset and then assign it to your character.
But if I open ours up here, you'll see that if we come over to the far right side, this
will give us access to our assigned physics asset.
This is where you get access to all of the physics collision bodies on your character,
where you can create and edit and simulate these different bodies to see how your character
is going to react with physics.
And you add these to each of your joints and then you would manipulate the size of these
so that they encompass most of your mesh.
And these will be the actual assets that are reacting with the collision rather than the
actual mesh of the character.
And once you've set it up, if you hit these two little arrows at the top, you can simulate
and test how the collision bodies are reacting with one another.
So once you've created your physics asset and you've edited it and tested the simulation
to make sure it works okay, you're now ready to start simulating the physics on this skeletal
mesh.
So I'm going to show you how to set that up on two of our characters here and show you
how to set it up in two slightly different ways to show how one might react with your
character and one might not.
So the setup is actually quite simple.
If I drag two of our characters into the level here, I can set one up so that it reacts
to the player's capsule so we can run into this character and we can set the other up
so that it doesn't essentially.
But on both of these, in order for the physics to work, what I'm going to do is shift select
both and in the details panel, I'll search for simulate physics and just enable that.
And then with one of our characters, Quinn here, I'll search for collision and change
the preset from physics actor to rag doll.
Now using rag doll, it means that our player character won't be able to interact with the
physics component or the physics asset of Quinn.
Whereas with Manny here, if we keep our collision preset to physics actor, we will be able to
interact with them.
We will be able to run into them and sort of knock them around.
So if I hit play here, you can see that instantly both of our characters fall over and the physics
is reacting to the world.
And if I try and nudge Quinn or knock her around, you can see that we're not able to interact
with her.
Whereas if we nudge Manny around, you can see that our collision capsule is reacting with
Manny's physics asset.
Now that we can see that happening on a couple of different skeletal measures just sitting
in the level, let's see how we can add that to our player character.
So there might be a scenario where you want physics to act on your character because they've
been shot in the arm and you want the arm to dangle, for example.
To get this set up, we need to do the same two things that we did with our skeletal measures
in the level to our player character.
So we need to activate simulate physics and we need to set our collision type for the
character mesh.
Now this is something that we'll do inside our player character blueprint.
So if we come back to our content browser, go to third person and blueprints and open
up our third person and blueprint here.
So we're going to be using the two functions that we looked at a minute ago.
We want to do settle bodies below simulate physics and settle bodies below physics blend
weight.
We'll look at the two separately.
So first of all, let's set our collision profile for our character mesh.
I'm going to click and drag and bring in our character mesh from the components tab on
the left here.
And I'm going to pull off that output pin and search for set collision profile name,
which we have here.
Now this allows us to set the collision profile via the name.
And if we select our mesh here and search for collision, we can see that we have several
different presets that we could type in here.
Now we could change the characters mesh collision preset by default, but this is typically something
you'd want to activate as a certain point within your game.
So it's best to set it up within the event graph logic.
But what we want to do is set up ragdoll on our collision profile name here.
So what I'm going to do is type that in.
And it's case sensitive.
So make sure that you're typing it correctly with the correct cases.
And I'll just compile that.
I'm now going to right click and search for set all bodies below physics, simulate physics.
Now this will allow us to specify a bone name from where we want the physics to begin.
So just connect these two together.
And then in our bone name, I'm just going to pull off here and search for make literal
name.
And this will allow us to just type a name inside here of a bone that we know we want
to use as a starting point for our physics.
So here I'm just going to put, let's say, spine 01.
And we want to tick new simulation so that it activates every time we trigger the event
logic.
And we're going to trigger it with a keypad press.
So if I right click and just press number one on my keyboard, I can search for, or I
can pick up this number one.
And when we press, what we'll do is we'll set the collision profile name and we'll set
all bodies below spine 01 to simulate physics.
Now something I have noticed there, actually, is that that shouldn't be a capital letter.
So hopefully that'll correct that.
So if we jump into our test level again and hit play, you can see that nothing has changed
on our character yet.
But as soon as I press one, you can see that our character slumps over and all of the bones
going from spine 01, all the bone chains after spine 01 are now fully simulated.
So we can run around and physics will just be reacting to however our character is moving.
Now this can give you some pretty cool results.
But what if you want to control the strength of the physics?
So if I hit escape and come back to our character blueprint here, just going to zoom in a little
bit and give ourselves a bit more space.
We're going to take a look at, or we're going to add on the physics blend weight function
that we looked at earlier.
So if I right click, search for set all bodies below physics blend weight.
We can just connect this on the end because we already have our make literal name.
We can plug that in.
And let's just experiment and try like a 0.5 blend weight and see what difference we get.
So hopefully what we'll have here is the animation of our character running around and jumping
around will still play.
But we'll get a little bit of physics or 50% of the strength of what we normally would
have for the physics playing on top.
So if I hit one, we can see they relax.
And as they run around, you can see the arms are kind of trying to run almost as if they're
a little bit drunk.
And when I jump, you can see the underlying animation is still kind of reacting and is
still animating there.
And so you can use this as like hit reactions or like I say, if your character loses an
arm or gets shot in the arm and you want that to just dangle so they can't use it anymore
or use it at 50% percent strength or whatever.
This is great for that kind of setup.
Now that we have an understanding of physics and how to get that set up on our skeletal
meshes, we're going to record this as an animation and then play it back through sequencer using
take recorder.
And this is great for sort of pre-baking physics animations into a predictable sequence.
So I've set up a big Pachinko machine obstacle course for our two skeletal meshes and when
I hit play or hit simulate, you can see that they all and interact with the blocks on their
way down.
And you can see that each time we play it, they do something slightly different.
So what we're going to do is record one of these and have that as like a reliable playback
for a physics animation.
We'll be recording using take recorder and you can access that via window, cinematics,
take recorder.
Now since version 5.1, this is defaultly enabled in the engine, but if you're using an earlier
version, you might find that you have to enable it as a plugin.
And you would do that by entering the access in the settings here, go into plugins and
just searching for take recorder and activating it there.
You probably need to restart your engine, but after that you should be able to access
take recorder through the options above.
Now take recorder is a great tool that allows you to record and save shots of whatever is
happening in your level.
Now this might be animation of a character or objects in the level or physics simulations
like we're about to do now, or you might even have a mocap actor connected directly
to the engine and you want to capture their performance.
So it's a really strong virtual production tool that allows you to iterate quite quickly
and quite easily in a lot of different ways.
So how does it work?
Well if we take a look at the UI first, up here you can set the name of your capture
and then determine which take you're on quite easily at the top.
And this big red button is how you'd start your recording.
Up the top left here you can use this icon to clear out any pending takes which would
delete any tracks that you have in an open sequence at the bottom.
This icon allows you to review your last recording.
So once you've captured something you could press that icon and then it'll open the sequence
that it recorded into and allow you to play it straight away.
This icon will allow you to record into an existing sequence.
So if you've got something else you want to happen in the level and that's set up in
a sequence you could record into that sequence and have the two things happen at the same
time.
And with this little drop down box here you can pick one of those sequences that you have
in the content browser to record into.
Here you can access the takes browser which is essentially where you'll be saving all
of your recorded takes.
This toggles the sequence for you on and off and this settings cog will open up the general
settings for the take recorder.
So where you can specify things like where you're saving your takes, timecode settings,
audio settings, animation settings and there's a useful thing down here called countdown
which by default is normally set to three seconds but for our setup here I've set it
to zero seconds just so we can capture everything from the beginning a little more easily without
having to wait for a countdown.
Now let's go ahead and see if we can capture a take.
But before we can record anything with take recorder we have to specify what is we want
to record it won't just capture the whole scene for you.
So if we come up to the take recorder UI here and hit plus source this is where we can choose
things that we have inside our level and we have Mali and we have Quinn.
So I'll just add those two as a source.
Now you can set up presets here so if you're constantly finding that you're trying to capture
the same few assets or same few actors you could save these as a preset and then each
time you load this up you can load that preset in and it means you won't have to load them
in individually each time.
Now if I come over to simulate and then quickly hit record when we're simulating you'll see
that we're capturing your two animations here and then I press stop and that'll save the
sequence.
Now the sequence isn't immediately available to preview but we can access it by reviewing
our last recording or with our drop down box here based on the name and take that we'd
set up earlier.
So if we just review our last sequence we can see that as we scrub through we have the
animation playing on our two characters where we're no longer relying on the unpredictability
of the physics we just have the animations baked onto these two characters here.
Now the way that these sequences are set up is you record into a master sequence and each
actor that you add as a source gets their own subsequence which means that you could
double click to open these subsequences and edit all the content individually.
Now before you can do any editing you'll find that the sequences by default come locked
so if you just click the lock up there that will allow you to move them around, retime
things, you can even add and edit animations inside here using control rig and anything
that you'd normally be able to do with animations inside a sequencer.
Whenever you've finished making any sort of animation edits you could always right click
your character and then bake animation sequence so that you have that as its own animation
sequence that you could use somewhere else in the project.
And to return to take recorder to capture something new you just hit the back arrow
at the top here.
All that will do is reset your sequencer and start you off with a new take.
So something else you can do with take recorder is record live gameplay so if we were to hit
plus source and add our player to our capture list I'll toggle off the two skeleton meshes
that we were capturing before and if I hit play and then record you can see that we're
now capturing our character's performance.
So if there was some sort of locomotion thing you wanted to capture of your character moving
around the level and you wanted to show off all your animation blueprint work that you
had this would be a great way to do that.
If I hit escape we can review this capture and scrub through and just see the animation
playing and you can do the same sort of things here.
So with this we could throw in a control rig, we could edit the animation, change the timings,
clean it up and then bake it out again once you're happy with it and you can use it elsewhere
in the project.
Just before wrapping up I wanted to share this slide that has some useful links on here
for things like more information on blend nodes within the engine, how to set up your
physics assets in the editor, also how to connect a mocap solution to the engine so
you can preview your actors inside, as well as a pretty useful link for some more information
on physics driven animation inside the engine.
So just to wrap up we've covered quite a few different things in this course.
We've seen a handful of different ways in how we can blend animations together, whether
that's blending them additively or cross blending them and then choosing different parts of
our skeletal mesh to blend these animations with.
Then we took a brief look at state machines and saw how one of those might be constructed
and even branched out into blending with physics, before then seeing how we can capture everything
with take recorder and save our animations out to use elsewhere in the project.
So thank you very much for listening and working along if you did and if you want to keep developing
be sure to check out the other animation courses we have available and best of luck with animation
blending in the future.